just before we get started with today's
video thank you to keeps for sponsoring
it did you know that two out of every
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35. you're soon gonna be joining
the club guys yes for me it was more
like 25 but you know who's counting i
wish keeps have been around when i was
younger because advancements in science
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have
look it's too late for me my hair's not
coming back but you didn't have to be
like me you could stop your hair loss
early thanks to keep keeps offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved drugs for treating hair loss so
you might have tried them before but
you've never tried them at a price this
low yes if you were thinking oh my god
simon this is a medicine thing it's
gonna be super expensive well
no with keeps it just starts at 10
a month how does it work well you don't
have to visit a doctor's office just you
schedule a quick online consult and then
a little bit later discrete package
arrives at your door you can use it in
the privacy of your own home so if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair like it's not going to fix itself i
promise you that do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash biographics or click the
link in the description below and you
will receive 50 of your first order and
now today's video
on january the 10th 49 bc julius caesar
did something that changed the course of
history he ignored orders from the roman
senate to disband his armies and instead
he crossed the rubicon river into italy
something considered treason a civil war
erupted that ultimately led to the
demise of the republic and the rise of
the roman empire thus solidifying julius
caesar's place as the most famous and
influential roman of all time you're
probably familiar with that story but
you might not know that 40 years earlier
somebody else did the same thing a man
named sulla feeling betrayed by the
machinations of his political opponents
and benefiting from the unwavering
support of his troops sulla marched into
rome and chased away his rivals then a
few years later he did the same thing
again except that this time his enemies
were ready for him leading to the first
civil war in roman history and causing
sulla to become the first man to seize
power from the roman republic
by force
[Music]
lucius cornelius sulla was born in 138
bc in patioli near naples today known as
posuoli as his name might suggest he was
part of one of the oldest patrician
houses in rome jen's cornelia however in
sulla's time that name didn't carry much
weight anymore the family had lost most
of its wealth and respect following the
actions of one of its ancestors publius
cornelius ruffanus plutarch has given us
the most detailed account of sulla's
life and he said that ruffanus disgraced
himself while serving as consul around
300 bc although his actions weren't
exactly front-page scandal material
apparently all he did was amass more
than his allotted share of silver for
this rufunus was expelled from the
senate and his family subsequently lost
a lot of its wealth and power it's not
like they were poor not by a long shot
but plutarch mentions that sulla when he
was young lived in cheap lodgings that
were only mildly better than those of a
freedmen aka a commoner in his youth
sulla lived by the study hard play-hard
mantra he was fond of wine and women and
often engaged in revelry in the company
of actors and musicians a practice he
continued all his life for when sulla
was once at a table he underwent a
complete change as soon as he betook
himself to good fellowship and drinking
so that comic singers and dancers found
him anything but ferocious it was this
laxity which produced in him a diseased
propensity to amorous indulgence and an
unrestrained voluptuousness from which
he did not refrain even in his old age
in order to improve his financial
situations was not above serving as a
boy toy in his early twenties he
received two legacies that he used to
enter politics the first was from his
stepmother but the other was from a rich
widow named nicopolis who was so
impressed with the young man's fortitude
that she named sulla as her heir his
first notable position was that of a
questor during the consulship of the man
who would eventually become his
arch-nemesis gaius marius in 112 bc roma
declared war on the kingdom of namidia
in north africa because they'd supported
hannibal during the punic wars this
conflict became known as the jagerstein
war named after the king of numeria
jagertha it didn't turn out to be the
walk in the park that rome had hoped for
four consoles fought namidia and they
all came back defeated and humiliated
until gaius marius took command in 107
bc at first it seemed like marius was
destined to meet the same fate if not
for the devious actions of his new
questa in order to get to jagatha sulla
appealed to his ally king barkus of
mauritania who agreed to betray the
namidian ruler in exchange for the
western half of his kingdom even so this
still was a massive risk for sulla who
stepped right into the lion's den of
bacchus's camp escorted only by a
handful of soldiers the trap that he
laid for jugartha could have just as
easily been his own undoing if bacchus
decided that he preferred the favor of
numidia over that of rome but the
mauritanian king delivered on the goods
jagertha and a small retinue
unsuspectingly entered the mauritanian
camp his soldiers were cut down
immediately while the numidian king was
brought to rome in chains where he died
in prison in 104 bc
[Music]
as we all know rome was never really the
live and let live kind of place while it
was engaged in the jigarcian war it also
took part in another conflict against
another confederation of germanic tribes
led by the simbri that migrated into
roman controlled territory the cimbrian
war as it was called saw rome suffer
several losses in its early stages
including the humiliating battle of
orozio which gave the roman republic its
worst defeat since hannibal over a
hundred years prior once again gaius
marius was the one tasked with
vanquishing rome's enemies basically he
was given carp lost by the senate to do
whatever he wanted as long as he stopped
the germanic tribes from marching into
rome a danger which had become a very
real possibility given how things were
going marius was fortunate that for
whatever reason the cymbrians did not
press their advantage if they would have
invadedly immediately following their
victory at arucio then they would have
almost certainly been able to sack the
eternal city despite the brewing discord
between gas marius and sulla the former
recognized the talent of the latter
which is why marius continued to recruit
sulla into his service even promoting
him to a leg ace and giving him command
of his own legion for his part sulla
showed off his value first when he
defeated the textus aegis and captured
their chieftain corpulus and then when
he persuaded the marsey tribe to leave
the germanic confederation and ally
itself with rome things seemed to be
going well but they took a turn in 102
bc guys marius had just received the
consulship for the fourth time but
instead of serving under him solo
requested to be transferred to the other
consul quintus letatius catalyst
plutarch described catalyst as a worthy
man but too sluggish for arduous
contests and maybe this is exactly what
sulu was looking for a lazy boss who had
passed down their responsibilities to
him cause marius was too ambitious for
this but catalyst entrusted solo with
important enterprises thus enabling him
to achieve power and glory in battle
when sula was in charge of provisions he
not only made sure his own soldiers
lived in plenty but sent the extra
rations to marius as men with a cheeky
wink and a nod a pure owl torns that
forewarned the strife and violence yet
to come after rome won the cimbrian war
ziller had earned enough personal fame
that he could pursue a successful
political career in 97 bc he was made
praetor urbanus in rome and later served
as pro-prater in the province of celesia
while their sula had to travel to nearby
cappadocia to help restore king ariel
barzones to the throne he had been
overthrown by mithridates the sixth king
of pontus who wanted to install one of
his own sons on the throne it is
unlikely that rome actually cared about
arya barzan's their main concern was to
limit the influence of mithridates whose
power had grown to the point that he had
become a serious threat but more on that
later but now sulla did as asked
restored arya barzanese to the throne of
cappadocia without too much hassle and
he returned to roman 93 bc just in time
to be impeached for bribery by a man
named sensarinus fortunately for him
this sensoriness never appeared at the
trial for whatever reason so the whole
thing was dropped until it was back on
track to leading rome and yet another
war
when sulla arrived in rome he discovered
mounting tensions between the romans and
the other groups of confederates who
lived in italy collectively known as
saki primarily led by the marcy and the
sam knight they didn't want to be
regarded as second class citizen anymore
they wanted roman citizenship and equal
rights and unsurprisingly rome didn't
want to give them this and thus the
social began in 93 bc sula primarily
fought against the sam knights and the
penny in southern italy he successfully
besieged the cities of pompei and
herculaneum before capturing the main
settlement of the herpini a killarney
his greatest triumph was outside the
city of nola where he overwhelmed an
army of twenty thousand pompeians
including their general cluntius he
annihilated them with a show of
unbridled and remorseless force like
mount vesuvius itself the war ended in
87 bc with another roman victory and
sulla was named consul for the first
time in 88 bc at the age of 50. for his
actions sulla was awarded the grass
crown which although it didn't sound too
impressive was actually the highest
military distinction of the roman
republic clinty the elder described what
made this crown so special but as for
the crown of grass it was never
conferred except at a crisis of extreme
desperation never voted except by the
acclamation of the whole army and never
to anyone but to him who had been its
preserver other crowns were awarded by
the generals to the soldiers this alone
by the soldiers and to the general
before the social war was even over the
roman republic was already embroiled in
another conflict in asia remember
mithridates king of pontus who tried to
take over cappadocia well he did it
again in the summer of 89 bc and this
time he was successful while he was
there he also conquered the neighboring
kingdom of bithynia which was a client
state of rome and in 88 bc he carried
out the asiatic vespers a genocide of
all romans and other latin-speaking
groups estimates of casualties range
between 80 and 150 000 people and once
he had done this war became inevitable
the first mithridatic war began in 89 bc
the commission to lead the troops was a
dream job for every general in rome
because it promised to be rich in
plunder and prestige as consul and the
premier military leader of that time the
honor went to sulla to the chagrin of
gaius marius who still coveted the
position even though he was almost 70
years old by that point fortunately for
him sula's rise brought him plenty of
other enemies all marius had to do was
conspire with one of them tribune
publius sulpicious rufus to strip sulla
of the command and grant him to himself
when word of the betrayal reached sully
he decided he wasn't going to just lie
down and take it the strife between him
and marius had been brewing for a long
time and now it was time to act sullives
let the support of his men roughly
thirty thousand soldiers so he did
something unprecedented he marched on
rome stiller first captured the
esquiline gate and as he and his army
were making their way through the
streets of rome they were pelted with
rocks by the unarmed masses who had
taken refuge on the roofs of their homes
tulla's response was extreme as he
ordered his men to begin setting fire to
the houses of those who attacked them by
this point guys marius knew he was in
deep deep trouble he made a last-ditch
attempt to secure protection by asking
the slaves and gladiators to take up
arms on his behalf but shockingly they
refused marius quickly fled the city
with his tail tucked between his legs
while his co-conspirator sulpicius was
betrayed and killed by one of his
servants now that sulla was in charge he
convened the senate and placed a death
sentence on gaius marius and a few of
his close supporters as you might expect
zilla's actions brought him the enmity
of the senate and the steps he took to
try and win them back had little success
to show that the republic was still free
he allowed one of his political
opponents lucius sinner to become consul
which turned out to be a foolish move
afterward sulla concerned himself again
with the war against mithridates
unsurprisingly he was confirmed as the
commander once more and he made plans to
travel to asia as soon as sulla was out
of italy lucius sinner began conspiring
with gaius marius who had retreated to
north africa in 87 bc marius returned
from exile with an army and charged rome
he basically repeated sulla's playbook
but wanted to show everyone that he
could be much much worse what followed
were five days of chaos death and
violence as he and sinner decapitated
many of sula's supporters and displayed
their heads on the rost trap the
elevated platforms which faced the
senate house as a nice little reminder
of what happened to those who went
against them eventually they stopped
making distinctions between friend and
foe and started killing people whose
property they coveted in 86 bc marius
and sinha put themselves forward as
candidates for consulship and surprise
surprise they were both elected
unfortunately we never got an ultimate
battle between the two fierce rivals
because just two weeks after becoming
consul gaius marius died of natural
causes leaving his position to another
of synod allies lucius valerius flaccus
while this mayhem was going on in rome
solar focused on his war against
mithridates and started with his greek
allies at this point in history the
greeks had only been under roman
hegemony for a few decades so many of
them jumped at the opportunity when
mithridates came along and offered to
help them escape the roman yoke of
oppression however when sulla showed up
with his legions armed to the teeth and
ready for war they realized that life
under roman rule might not be so bad
after all so they switched sides again
and sent ambassadors to ask sula for
forgiveness one notable exception was
aristian the tyrant king of athens who
pined for the city's glory days and
remained allied with mithridates in the
hopes that athens might again flourish
as the beacon of culture of the greek
world thus the city-state became sulla's
first target as he laid siege not only
on athens but also on the nearby port
city of piraeus this would stop food
shipments from getting to athens it was
ruthless but effective soon enough the
city was a wretched site to behold
struck by famine deaths even cannibalism
and by early spring 86 bc athens and
aristian were executed by this point
some of sewell's supporters who managed
to escape the carnage back in rome had
begun arriving at his camp so stillen
knew that the marius in a faction had
taken over and declared him an enemy of
the state but as we said gaius marius
was already dead by then and he would
soon be joined by his replacement consul
lucious valerius flaccus flaccus had
been given the task of dealing with both
sulla and mithridates and considering
that he only had two legions this was
somewhat optimistic but flakus never
even made it to the battlefield because
he was betrayed by one of his officers a
man named flavius fimbria who clearly
thought that he was better suited for
the job in nicomedia fimbria
assassinated flaccus by cutting off his
head and throwing it into the sea then
he declared himself the new commander
and went to fight mithridates fimbria
was more successful than expected
against the king of pontus but then
something happened which he'd not
anticipated as his two enemies banded
together against him mithradartis
realized that the war was lost so he
made peace with sulla he agreed to
renounce bithynia and cappadocia pay
sulla 2000 talents and give him 70 ships
and in exchange sula would confirm
mithridates as the rightful ruler of his
other dominions and get him recognized
as an ally of rome and then of course
there was the matter of dealing with
fimbria which did not prove difficult at
all sulla's much larger army surrounded
the enemy camp at which point fimbria's
men mutinied and switched sides fimbria
fled to pergamon where he entered the
temple of asclepius and committed
suicide becoming sulla's third roman
enemy to die without actually fighting
him and he wouldn't be the last at this
rate the whole matter would have
probably been settled itself if sulla
simply waited long enough but instead he
intended to march on rome again
back in rome word arrived that flaccus
had been less than stellar in his
mission and lucius sinner realized that
sula would now be returning to italy to
look for a fight besides him other
leading members of his faction were a
man named cabo who basically replaced
flakus and the son of gaius marius gaius
marius the younger meanwhile silla also
had some strong support since sinner and
gaius marius had made plenty of enemies
during their spree of assassinations
exiles and confiscations people you
might remember such as pompeii and
marcus crassus had an axe to grind with
them so they raised armies in support of
sula the war began with a triumphal
before he even reached italy in 84 bc
lucius sinner was killed by his own men
most likely following a mutiny this left
carbo and gas marius the younger in
charge as well as two newly elected
consuls gas nubanus and scepio asiaticus
in 83 bc solar landed in southern italy
his first battle took place near capua
against norbhanus and it was a decisive
victory he then encountered the other
console scepio with his army but the two
sides never came to blows scepio's
troops consisted mainly of inexperienced
soldiers who were not eager to fight
still as veterans many of them deserted
others switched sides and scepio had no
choice but to surrender and enter talks
with his enemy for his part sulla tried
to be diplomatic and send skibio back
with messages for the senate and his
strategy seemed to pay off more and more
men not just soldiers but also statesmen
and generals were siding with sulla the
third major encounter of the war
occurred in april 82 bc when sulla took
on gaius marius the younger and his main
force it was another victory priscilla
who forced marius to retreat and take
refuge in the fortress city of preenesta
zuller left one of his generals to lay
siege on marius and he continued his way
towards rome meanwhile he had received
good news from his allies who had bested
the enemy and other parts of italy
pompeii in particular was responsible
for giving carbo a crushing defeat at
clusium which resulted in 20 000
casualties and most of the survivors
taking their ball and going home the
decisive battle was fought in early
november 82 bc outside the walls of rome
by this point
none of the leaders of the marius sinner
faction were even involved anymore and
their army consisted mostly of other
italian people such as sam knights and
lukanians even so the battle of the
colin gate as it was called almost ended
in a shocking defeat for sulla it was
the actions of marcus crassus that won
the day as he completely routed the
enemy on the right wing while sulla was
struggling to keep control on the left
with the civil war one tiller was
appointed dictator by the senate he
showed little mercy to his enemies as he
executed or banished those who opposed
him and confiscated their properties
cabo norbanas marius the younger all
died in 82 bc while scepio asiaticus was
banished whilst was unforgiving to his
foes he also showed himself to be very
grateful to his friends men like pompei
and marcus crassus had their careers
jump started following their
participation in the war as they all
became fabulously rich and powerful once
the rewards and punishments have been
doled out tiller gave himself immunity
for all of his past actions and served
as consul in atbc the following year
once his consulship had ended sulla
willingly renounced his power giving an
impassioned speech in the forum to
explain his actions and how he didn't
seek tyranny but it was thrust upon him
apparently it was convincing enough that
even statesmen such as cicero or
historians like plutarch and appian who
despised sulla for his actions still
grudgingly had to admit a certain
admiration for him in 79 bc sula retired
to his villa in naples where he wrote
his memoirs and once again spent his
days in the company of actors and
musicians he died the following year age
60 and was given a public funeral with
honors back in rome his tomb was placed
in the campus martius which proudly
displayed sulla's motto in life no
better friend no worse enemy
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]
you